Barbarian is full of some truly eye-popping
scares.
Literally.
Part of what makes "Barbarian" such a rollercoaster
of terror is how it keeps its answers in the
dark to let your mind simmer on the worst
possibilities.
The moment Tess, played by Georgina Campbell,
arrives at the double-booked rental, her first
discovery is learning somebody else is staying
in the house - Keith played by Bill Skarsgård.
She keeps her guard up but eventually softens
to the idea.
One night Keith goes missing and Tess hears
his faint screaming coming from downstairs.
Tess enters the dark basement and manages
to find a secret doorway by pulling on a rope
coming out of the wall.
The doorway opens up to a pitch-black space
and makes your mind rattle with possibilities.
"Nope."
Tess works up the courage to enter and as
she travels into the dark space that's when
the stakes of the movie rise exponentially.
Tess discovers a dingy and desolate hidden
side room for the first time, which truly
makes for a horrifying moment.
The disgusting mattress, sleazy lighting,
and video camera make it feel like Tess is
walking into the setting of a snuff film,
which sadly isn't far from the truth.
The twists and turns mount on top of each
other as the film plays on your assumptions.
AJ, played by Justin Long, finds Frank's bedroom
where he discovers the snuff films Frank,
played by Richard Brake, recorded as he kidnapped
women throughout his life.
The room Tess found earlier in the film serves
as both an immediate scare and a super terrifying
breadcrumb leading us to Frank's backstory.
It's a story that began decades ago.
The final discovery Tess makes is that the
Mother everyone has feared all this time is
also a victim of her father's abuse.
The Mother is a constantly terrifying threat
throughout "Barbarian," but it's her initial
debut that's the most terrifying since it
comes out of nowhere.
By the time the Mother enters the picture,
you're completely engaged with Tess and Keith's
fun chemistry and their growing bond as well
as the intriguing mystery that's afoot.
When she finally does arrive towards the end
of the first act, you're totally in the dark
about what's really going on and it makes
her shambling out of the shadows absolutely horrifying.
Just as Tess and Keith reunite in a dark and
dingy tunnel, the Mother comes from the shadows
to deliver a terrifying fright and perform
a shocking and bloody kill on Keith by repeatedly
bashing his head against a wall.
It's a moment where the horrors of "Barbarian"
really come out to play and it's an incredibly
memorable way to hook horror fans through
a fantastic reveal of a terrifying horror antagonist.
AJ is such a clueless person, that when he
first enters the house, he mostly ignores
all the warning signs that things are off.
He's so hopelessly dim that even when he finds
the secret room in the basement, he thinks
nothing of it and whips out the tape measure
to see if he can get more value out of the property.
AJ unknowingly brings himself deeper into
trouble as he travels farther into the tunnels.
Eventually, the Mother starts to toy with
AJ by messing with his tape measurer, even
ripping it away from him.
It's a great moment of comedy turning to horror
as it kicks off a wild chase sequence through
the tunnels that leaves AJ trapped and reveals
Tess is still alive.
Plus, the tape measure comes back later in
the film to nearly thwart Tess' escape and
provide a good jump scare in an already-tense
moment.
After AJ and Tess meet while being captured
by The Mother, you can't help but wonder what
she plans to do with these two, and the answer
is truly creepier than one's wildest imagination.
Viewers quickly learn why the creature is
credited as "The Mother" as she tries to perform
motherly behavior on Tess and AJ to make them
like her children.
However, given the Mother's grotesque look,
motherly duties have never looked so morbid.
"You cannot get upset."
The entire sequence is a total nail-biter
as Tess' survival instincts force her to blend
into the situation by reluctantly drinking
the baby bottle filled with the Mother's breast milk.
It's a nasty moment that hits you right in
the gut, but it's ultimately a smart choice
given what happens to AJ when he refuses.
It's tough not to be squirming in your seat
when the Mother drags AJ through the tunnels
and breastfeeds him.
Overall, "Barbarian" certainly makes you understand
why the Mother earns her name and it couldn't
be more disturbing, strange and heartbreaking.
After both AJ and an injured Tess leave the
house, they are sheltered by Andre, played
by Jaymes Butler, a local homeless man, who
allows them a moment of solace as the Mother
continues to look for them.
It's here that Andre discloses the Mother's
gut-wrenching origins and tries to give AJ
and Tess a moment to catch their breath.
But good moments don't last for long in "Barbarian,"
and with one little comment about his place
being safe, they end up being Andre's famous
last words.
The sudden reappearance of the Mother results
in a great jump scare and not only kicks off
a thrilling final chase but delivers a truly
brutal kill as the Mother rips Andre's arm
off and beats him to death.
"Barbarian" features some surprisingly gruesome
kills throughout and Andre's is no different.
It's a bloody end to a character with good
intentions and a memorably terrifying moment
that breaks the calming atmosphere with sudden
terror.
One of the earliest scares in "Barbarian"
comes when Tess and Keith are first in the
house together for the night and Keith has
a night terror that makes for an unnerving sequence.
After Tess wakes up from someone or something
opening her door and making a creepy sound
while she is sleeping, she finds that Keith
is wrestling and moaning on the couch.
What follows is an absolutely nerve-racking
sequence showing Tess walking towards Keith
as he has some serious night terrors.
Tess approaching Keith is purely thrilling
and the growing sounds of Keith's cries of
terror increase the tension immensely.
The jump scare that comes from Keith suddenly
waking up delivers a perfect jolt to viewers
and acts as a great end stinger to a scary
sequence.
It all ends with some good laughs with the
awkward exchange between Tess and Keith, but
it's an unforgettably tense moment early in
the film that sets the tone perfectly and
instills some good chills.
"No, no, no, wait!"
Even though we know that AJ is basically the
worst person ever as it becomes clear that
he's guilty of sexual assault, Tess doesn't
know that and does everything in her power
to try and save him.
After Tess initially escapes, she goes back
into the house to traverse the dark corridors
and eventually makes her way back to the Mother's
room.
Soon after, she notices a light peeking out
through the darkness, and with one little
response, she finds herself on the ground
with a bullet in her gut.
What Tess didn't realize is that AJ was able
to get a pistol from Frank, and is now nervously
going through the tunnels still believing
that the Mother is hiding somewhere.
Thus, when he sees a shadowy figure standing
just a short distance away, he doesn't hesitate
to fire.
Only after he fires does he learn it was Tess
standing there.
The entire sequence is thrilling.
The build-up to Tess returning into the house
is incredibly tense, and the moment she sees
the light of AJ's phone leaves you silent
and then instantly frightened by the well-timed
jump scare of the gunshot.
You're left even more scared afterward as
Tess clings on as she bleeds for the rest
of the film.
Just as all hope seems lost for Tess after
the cops don't believe her and she's once
again left on her own, she decides to take
the Mother head-on with the help of something
mentioned by Andre.
Amongst his ramblings, Andre mentions that
the Mother only comes out at night and with
that knowledge, Tess manages to ram her car
into the Mother when she appears, pinning
her against the house and in the process breaking
the windshield.
The anticipation leading up to the moment
the Mother rises from the small basement window
is killer and when she does appear it's through
a sudden scare.
It's incredibly creepy to watch her slowly
crawl out of the tiny window hole and there
is something satisfying about Tess finally
taking action against the Mother to try and
go save AJ.
Not to mention, it's super scary to see the
Mother snarl and scream at Tess after she
gets hit by the car, but it doesn't keep her
down for long.
The entire last act of "Barbarian" is full
of terrifying moments as AJ and Tess are in
a fight for their lives against the Mother.
While AJ might have a moment of realization
about his behavior, that doesn't mean he's
a completely different person who has magically
turned into an unselfish hero.
Actually, he's the opposite of a hero as they
approach the finale.
By this point, AJ has accidentally shot Tess,
and he tries to sacrifice her in the final
moments of the chase just to save his skin.
This forces the Mother to jump down and save
Tess.
It's a moment that's incredibly suspenseful
since you don't know if Tess or the Mother
survive the fall.
At first, it seems like the Mother isn't getting
back up.
Unfortunately for AJ, she does, and she's
not letting him get away this time.
AJ's death is one of the gnarliest kills of
the film as the Mother not only pokes out
his eyes but crushes his head with her bare
hands.
Director Zach Cregger doesn't hide anything
either.
It's such an incredibly gory and gross kill
that's satisfying because of how terrible
AJ is, but it's also incredibly horrifying
because it's so graphic.
No one is forgetting this kill, that's for
sure.